what is subtext the subtext is the thing
that is not being said
so
if
I say
I'm very happy to meet you
um what is that what am I not saying
am I not was the thing I'm not saying is
I've been waiting for this appointment
for six months and I can't understand
why it took so long
and then you know I I'm very happy to
meet you or or or or is it that uh or is
it something else it you know it's the
thing that's not being said and and so
that can come in a lot of forms it can
be
um it can be the uh the history
you know I uh again somebody asked how
are you and I say I'm fine and I don't
give you my whole medical history right
it's uh it's uh it's a long one and uh
so I don't I don't give that to you but
that's always behind every time I say
I'm fine
you know I'm a little bit grateful that
I'm still alive right so that's that's
the subtext for me every time I say I'm
fine but if if you say uh oh here's a
great way to explain subtext
let's say that you have
renovated your house renovated your
living room and put a lot of time and
energy and money into it
and then a friend comes to the door for
the first time and they come in and they
say
oh you changed everything around
right
what's the subtext right it's like they
don't like it that's the subtext right
and but if they come in and they say you
changed everything around then you know
that they did like it so that's we
subtext happens in our daily lives all
the time it's you know it affects the
way that the line comes out it's it's
the emotional Sanford Meisner used to
talk about there's no the emotions of
the scene or a river the words are boats
that float on that River so the subtext
is the emotional River of of of the
scene or or the of the character and
um
so uh and so sometimes it's a line
reading you know those are two different
line readings for two different subtexts
having to do with this one topic
um it can be you know different a
different history uh it can be a
different uh verb that's what I did with
the verbs with uh don't lie to me could
I read a few couple a few lines these
are mine that I came up with oh great
okay and and so maybe you can critique
me on my delivery of them and also uh
the subtext
okay so the first one is um
I love that dress on you Judith
did Paul tell you he did tell you right
that we used to date
here's another one
dad knows
he wants the money put back in his
account immediately
okay last one
your check is waiting for you in payroll
Security will walk you down and you have
five minutes to clean out your desk
that was awesome
you're hired okay great I'm gonna cast
you you're fantastic okay thanks but uh
so so different different meanings for
each one so maybe we could start with I
love that dress on you by the way did
Paul tell you
meaning it's someone trying to sort of
undercut someone
compliment I don't know that that's how
I read into it sure sure yeah I think I
I think uh well I think you absolutely
got the idea of subtext the the I love
that dress on you that is not to be
taken literally
sure and it is it's uh it has a reason
behind it that's not the literal uh
meaning of the words it's yeah so so
subtext means that the things people say
they're not uh there's something else
behind it there's uh you could call it
an agenda or or uh
you know there's there's something else
now in that case in the case of the
first one the
um that person has is conscious of her
agenda I would say that that and her
intention I would say is to undermine
the person she's talking to sure with
the information that did you know I used
to date Paul that that you're that you
want to undermine uh the person you're
talking to and by beginning with uh uh
the compliment on the dress it's it's a
way to make the the knife in the
knife in the back even even sharper you
know by by uh it's and it's an opposite
okay throws the person off their game a
little bit Yeah so you're saying I love
that dress but the with the attention to
undermine right it's uh yeah ugly lovely
what about the other did you want to
talk more about the other two okay so
dad knows
he wants the money put back in his
account immediately
so sibling to Sibling Something's
Happened it involves money yeah
um yeah
uh well uh
uh
I guess what what did you feel your
intention was you know I guess you're
right when I when I look at it there's
there's less subtext it seems like it's
pretty obvious but it's not obvious at
all oh no you could do it you could I
could do it completely opposite okay
yeah I'll just try it sure sure
dad knows
when he wants the money put back in the
account
right away
that's that's true that's a softer
that's actually you know more caressing
maybe I may you know depends on the
history between these two maybe this
person has been having a rough time
maybe the person that your character is
talking to has been having a rough time
and uh
and or maybe they both colluded on this
rearranging of funds
and and maybe it's I'm the one that has
to put the the money back
I think the way you wrote it exactly
doesn't make it doesn't make it have to
be the person you're talking to so so uh
you know dad knows
and he wants the money put back you know
maybe it's like very practical my dad
knows he wants the money put back
immediately cover blown right that's
true it could be played different ways
so so the so the questions you have or
if you're looking at those lines on a
page are you know what is the history
did the two of these these two siblings
did they collude on these uh on whatever
happened to these uh funds or or uh
or is it the fault of that one or even
just the fault of this one so that's
where those are the kind of questions
that I always start out with with lines
like that are on a page uh you know I I
ask you know what what's the history
of this uh Caper whatever was done with
the money
right yeah I like that and then lastly
was just and maybe more self-explanatory
just um you know your check is waiting
for you in payroll Security will walk
you down after you've cleaned out your
desk and you have five minutes
yeah well that's a that's an example of
something that could be thought of as
exposition
but uh the way that you you read you
gave it an intention to punish
right which is very reasonable that that
this is the person who's up to here with
with that uh with that person who's
being relieved of their duties and um
and
the subtext that I heard when you read
that was that
this person is off my back out of my you
know this person it's this nightmare is
is gone but but again if you saw it on
the page there's other possibilities
that it could be it it it it could be
that this that the person speaking
fought to keep this uh
fought to keep this uh this person at
their job
and uh and is they could even be crying
or they were the reason the person's
fired so yeah there could be different
it could be yeah you know yeah I I
thought your choices were just marvelous
but but that's very uh helpful uh
example about you know if we saw it each
of those lines on a page we could really
ask all these questions to get at what
what their subtext is
and would it depend on the tone in which
they're said well tone is another word
for verb I think you know like a teasing
tone is the verb to tease
so
um yeah tone is another way of talking
about it
great I like the verbs because they're
so because they're so uh muscular
if a scene does not have subtext what
can a director do to add it in
you have to believe that it does have
subtext and look for it
that's I I just feel that so strongly
that uh there's no sometimes when I was
teaching workshops on uh with actors and
directors working together and bringing
in scenes that they'd worked on and
sometimes people will say well this is a
very straightforward scene
um
I would just say I want you to take that
out of your vocabulary this is a
straightforward scene there's no such
thing
and it if if it really is then probably
should be Rewritten so that there's
something extra in it you know so that
there's some twist something that that
lets us into the personalities and
predicaments of these of these
characters and or foreshadows something
in this story that uh yeah a
straightforward scene
probably doesn't belong in the movie
so so uh so and sometimes they need to
be Rewritten
but uh but sometimes the the filmmaker
hasn't looked hard enough
for uh for something else that could be
there
that's what I think so with
straightforward almost code for there's
no life to it that's it's too dry well
it's code for exposition oh okay
or or
a connector a connector scene this is a
connector scene this uh
yeah right okay so when you talked about
Neo in the one scene in your book
um you said it was sort of a connector
scene but it seemed like that wasn't
that straightforward I mean there was
you know he's having a memory of a
restaurant I believe oh yeah it's partly
you know how great the writing is but uh
because so much is evoked and such
there's so much imagery in it
so much uh imagery the image of the of
the uh
the uh noodle place
of the yeah the image of the noodle
place it it's so important you know it
gives us so because we see very little
of um
of
of Neo when he's Thomas Anderson
you know at the beginning of the of the
movie and and this gives us a whole
picture of Thomas Anderson sitting alone
in the noodle place on his lunch hour
or with somebody you know and and uh and
it it it's it evokes it it it takes us
somewhere I mean he goes somewhere we go
with him